es interesante hablar de Francia y de
Argentina porque tiene muchas
similitudes en cuanto a los títulos de
copas del mundo porque ambos ganaron su
primer título como locales Francia en el
98 y Argentina en 1978 pero quisiera
hablar un poquito Octavio de esa
selección francesa y de ese cambio que
ha dado precisamente de esa Copa del
Mundo del año de 1998 luego de un
proceso algo inestable en la década de
los 80 y 90 De hecho no asisten a Italia
90 donde Argentina también fue finalista
se pierde en la Copa del Mundo de 1994
en Estados Unidos pero luego desde 1998
ha sido un candidato un protagonista
consecuente en copas del mundo la
selección francesa Francia tiene que
estar Perdón tranquilos porque tienen
una generación que seguramente los va a
llevar a seguir peleando no cualquiera
llega a dos finales de manera
consecutiva Pero además dominando el
fútbol mundial desde el año 98 ellos
marcan una Pauta una diferencia han
peleado una de las copas del mundo le
han dejado el planeta un hombre como
cine de Zidane y ahora un hombre como
kilian mbappé eso marca una una
diferencia y genera una una historia una
generación tiene mucho talento en cuanto
a la función de su juveniles la cantidad
de jugadores que sacan la cantidad de
jugadores que tienen y Francia debe
estar Perdón contentos Porque además
Esta generación le peleó y mano a mano
Argentina es decir Esta generación no
perdió el partido y no le regaló el
partido Argentina le peleó hasta el
último minuto con todos los
inconvenientes que describía Juan y con
todo lo que sucedió entonces Francia
tiene que entender que evidentemente
para llegar ahí la gana uno solo pero
que ellos han sido una una selección y
un país que está enriqueciendo el fútbol
mundial y que nadie puede ver a Francia
de otra manera sino es como campeones
del mundo como un equipo que puede
seguir sumando a ese nivel que que ha
tenido a lo largo de los últimos tiempos
y un poco especulando qué va a pasar con
el técnico de Francia con the champs
contrato termina este año pero se
hablaba de que incluso gente como el
presidente Manuel macron quiere que
continúe y que se le van a ofrecer dos
años más Pero sabemos que que hay una
tiendita montada cerca de la federación
por parte de zinedine Zidane qué va a
pasar yo creería Omar lo que pasa es que
las elecciones son tan diferentes a los
clubes hay técnicos que son de
selecciones y hay técnicos que
evidentemente necesitan el día a día Yo
también Supongo que esto significa un
desgaste muy Bravo no lo ve en el físico
de los entrenadores yo que tengo familia
de entrenadores los pasan tres partidos
y se quedan sin cabello
esa la verdad es que sufren y toda la
familia que está alrededor de ellos lo
sufre más entonces lo los entrenadores
digamos a veces tienen que que hacer una
pausa de ya no tiene que demostrarle
nada a nadie cuando desean se agarró el
equipo nadie creía en que él iba a hacer
lo que hizo y es el el campeón como
capitán campeón como entrenador los
vuelve a llevar una final pelea Eurocopa
hace lo que hace Entonces si él decide
seguir tiene que tienen que tirar una
alfombra roja ahora si él decide parar
tomar un descanso y tomar otra otra
actividad en su en su vida también
Francia tiene mucha gente capacitada
para dirigir la selección Más allá de
Zidane y Y eso es es el camino de de un
fútbol de futuro que va a tener este
este seleccionado sin duda alguna y
también hay un caso similar con Lionel
escalón y también se habla mucho qué
será el futuro de Lionel escaloni si da
un paso al costado de la Selección
Argentina o decide ir a algún Club por
ahora ningún Club ha mostrado intereses
en Leonel escalón y son meras
especulaciones de la prensa Argentina
quizás pero también está ese debate en
la nación sureña sobre Qué puede pasar
de ahora en adelante con lío escaloni
para encarar lo que se viene de cara ya
a la Copa del 2026 los argentinos dirían
que hagan lo que quieran ya o sea le
ganó la Copa América ganó la finalísima
ganó el mundial de fútbol Si se quiere
ir a su casa que no dirija más y digamos
a partir de hoy escalón iba a tener
digamos muchísimas opciones seguramente
Chiqui Tapia que está con ellos ahí el
presidente de la asociación de fútbol
argentino le va a ofrecer la renovación
él es un tipo muy joven tiene muchísimas
cosas por dar todavía Argentina tiene un
camino con Esta generación de jugadores
que que está arrancando evidentemente
Será muy duro el post Messi porque a
partir de ahora el post Messi va a ser
durísimo pero no será nunca tan duro
como para para no poder afrontarlo con
tres títulos encima no Y eso le va a dar
una cancha a escalón y para decir lo que
él quiere hacer también además que otro
de los activos de escalón y en su
juventud y y es importante que que
siendo un técnico de de poca experiencia
muy joven pudo manejar un vestuario de
jugadores Como por ejemplo de figuras
enormes como el tamaño de Lionel Messi
que incluso a nivel etario están pues
muy cerca de él no Pero por supuesto
además la mayoría fueron o hay un grupo
y fueron compañeros de él es que yo
pienso hoy en el técnico de Argentina de
umar Pablo aimar Walter Samuel Roberto
Ayala Leonel escalón y todos sufrieron y
sufrieron como jugadores hoy están
siendo campeones del mundo con jugadores
que alguno de ellos fueron compañeros
como el caso de Messi que en algún
momento de de su carrera Entonces
evidentemente voy por el mismo lado de
champs hay un desgaste brutal encima de
esto porque para ellos llevar a
Argentina hasta aquí con lo pasionales
que son en Argentina significa un
desgaste pero evidentemente van a tener
Carta abierta Y a partir de hoy se les
va a ver totalmente diferente a escalón
y por su juventud ya con tres títulos
encima y con todo lo demás va a tener el
camino que él decida tomar Y eso es lo
lo importante para una generación así
pero repito el tema acá será como
Argentina en cara de aquí en adelante el
post Messi sin importarles que acaban de
ser campeón del mundo o con el hambre de
seguir este camino de un grupo que que
la mayoría de ellos va a quedar en la en
la selección salvo contadas excepciones
de mes y Di María pero la mayoría tiene
el camino todavía empezando en la en la
selección